tungsten tungsten is a very hard and
heavy element it has a number of
important uses it is used in the
filament of lightbulbs the the ordinary
sort of light bulbs because it has more
or less the highest boiling point of any
element and therefore you can use it as
the filament and it can get very hot
without very much evaporation onto the
walls if you add iodine into the gas
around the bulb you can run it at even
higher temperatures the so-called quartz
halogen lamps and sometimes you see
these in upmarket cars so this is
tungsten tungsten is used as it as an
element material to form the very very
fine wire that we may have used in
old-style an electric light bulbs it's a
really quite wonderful metal and it's
it's actually used in nature but here we
have a really quite beautiful sample
this is a single crystal of tungsten
which is mounted tungsten carbide the
compound of tungsten and carbon is used
in the very tip the balls in the tip of
a Barrow pen or ballpoint pen really
quite amazing I've got some other
tungsten here somewhere and in fact here
is a very very fine wire of tungsten and
this is precisely the type of material
that was used in the formation of very
early electric light bulbs really quite
amazing metal there's also quite a nice
book by Oliver Sacks who's an Englishman
who now is a lives in America called
uncle tungsten they're not many books
that have chemical names in the title
and this is a story of his childhood and
how chemistry really had a big effect on
him
that's lovely